[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas una poderosa ola de
calor azota a europa occidental una masa
de aire cálido proveniente del norte de
áfrica llevó a países como francia y
reino unido- a lanzar alertas rojas en
sus territorios gran bretaña registró un
récord histórico de temperaturas
superando los 40 grados centígrados por
primera vez en su historia el martes
mientras que en francia los incendios en
el suroeste del país consumieron miles
de hectáreas fenómenos peligrosos que se
vuelven cada vez más comunes como
consecuencia del calentamiento global
informe de nuestros colegas de fondo
el calor infernal en portugal alimenta
agresivos incendios frente a muros de
llamas cerca de 3.000 bomberos e incluso
los habitantes que intentan combatir el
fuego con sus propios medios ramen esta
mañana sentí pánico veía los
helicópteros ahora de noche veo hasta
qué punto su horrible papel si melocos y
las llamas avanzan desde hace tres días
este vecino observa impotente como su
casa se reduce a cenizas más cerca del
bosque esta otra casa quedó calcinada
fue muy rápido de repente hubo mucho
humo y la casa estaba en llamas no
podemos hacer nada más
croacia también estás sofocada por las
llamas
frente a un macro incendio los
habitantes intentan contener el fuego
ayudados por bombarderos de agua apenas
visibles en un cielo lleno de humo
pero todavía arde a 150 metros de aquí
no tenemos que ir a ver intentar frenar
este fuego
carreras contrarreloj contra nuevos
focos de incendio
el agua imprescindible para andar en
españa donde sobre todo en el centro y
en el sur del país se llega a los 40
grados desde la mañana es un infierno
solo por andar puede darte un golpe de
calor en reino unido- las playas están
abarrotadas aquí hay profesionales del
turismo que sonríen ante estas
temperaturas extremas es fantástico
nosotros vivimos para esto por esto
hacemos negocio sin embargo los
servicios de emergencias médicas están
en alerta aparte de los casos menores
habituales llegan problemas serios de
insolaciones y golpes de calor la ola de
calor continuará esta semana y cada vez
se esperan más episodios parecidos como
consecuencia del cambio climático
los ataques rusos de los últimos días
han afectado ciudades en distintos
puntos de ucrania pero el grueso de la
potencia de fuego sigue concentrado en
la región oriental del donbass que rusia
busca controlar por completo para
conseguirlo moscú debe hacerse con
varias ciudades importantes entre ellas
crea motores con una población de
160.000 habitantes antes de la guerra
ésta es una de las más relevantes en la
provincia de daniel veamos más en el
siguiente informe de ludovico y gulliver
craik
rama torch la mayor ciudad del donbass
aún bajo control ucraniano está en el
punto de mira del ejército ruso las
autoridades regionales han aconsejado a
los residentes que huyan pero ni ná no
quiso abandonar su mercado y ahora dice
que incluso ve a los residentes realizar
hay que pagarle al alquiler hay que
encontrar un trabajo de dónde vamos a
sacar el dinero la gente salió los
primeros días con un poco de dinero pero
cuando no tienes nada que haces
tienen que irse porque no pueden pagar
no pueden comprar comida así que vuelven
aquí
y cuando le preguntamos a nena si tiene
una palabra para describir la vida en
crematorio es una de nuestras pensiones'
son escasas hay guerra nos bombardean
continuamente mírame tengo 70 años y
sigo trabajando ya no me quedan dientes
y no tengo con que comprarme unos nuevos
entre los clientes muchos soldados
esperan que su presencia sea
tranquilizadora pero también quieren
recordar las normas de seguridad
sí y también es bueno llevar un equipo
de primeros auxilios como el que veo con
usted siempre hay un riesgo de bombardeo
por lo que la gente tiene que ir a los
refugios cuando oyen las sirenas hay una
sensación de amenaza inminente en hama
tours que la plaza central fue atacada
el viernes y el sábado el ministro de
defensa ruso ordenó a sus ejércitos
elevar el nivel de actividad en todas
las zonas operativas de ucrania la
expulsión es su volar las ventanas de
los edificios cercanos estos
trabajadores están reforzando las
fachadas en previsión de nuevos ataques
pero aquí puedes admirar los resultados
de las supuestas últimas operaciones de
liberación de los rusos ya estamos
prácticamente en la primera línea así
que estamos preparados supongo que más
podemos hacer la vida siguieron
de repente las sirenas un sonido que se
ha vuelto tan familiar en hama tours que
ya no parece importarle a mucha gente en
ucrania los niños han sido uno de los
sectores de la población más afectados
por la guerra desde el 24 de febrero se
cuentan cientos de muertos pero miles
más han quedado heridos o han visto su
salud afectada como consecuencia de los
ataques indiscriminados de las fuerzas
rusas contra la población civil muchos
de ellos siguen su tratamiento en
ucrania y los más graves son evacuados
hacia otros países gracias al apoyo de
múltiples organizaciones nuestros
enviados especiales catalina gómez ángel
y oriol andrés gallart visitaron algunos
de los centros apoyados por unicef donde
se les brinda apoyo
miles de niños han sido víctimas de la
guerra más de 310 han fallecido y
cientos más han quedado heridos como
consecuencia a los ataques
indiscriminados de las fuerzas rusas los
casos más críticos son traídos hasta
hospitales en la ciudad de leh vivo aquí
en la unidad de reanimación del hospital
san nicolás el doctor diadema benz nica
tiene a su cargo un equipo de
especialistas que por eso empeño en
salvarlos como es el caso de este
pequeño que se debate entre la vida y la
muerte la mayoría llegan en condiciones
médicas muy difíciles vienen con
infecciones graves como consecuencia de
las heridas tienen que recorrer un gran
trayecto para llegar aquí
la mayoría de los pacientes llegan desde
el este del país a cientos de kilómetros
de distancia este pequeño de siete años
fue traído desde jarc y donde sufrió un
ataque cuando jugaba en un parque hoy
está fuera de peligro
mi hijo estaba en el epicentro del
ataque tuvo heridas muy graves el
diafragma el hígado una costilla partida
piezas de metralla entraron a sus
piernas es un milagro que esté vivo
decenas y decenas de niños que ya tenían
problemas antes de la guerra como
epilepsia o problemas en su crecimiento
han visto como su situación se empeora
con la llegada de la guerra
especialmente aquellos que viven en
poblaciones que son atacadas
constantemente por las fuerzas rusas
muchos de ellos han llegado al oeste del
país donde han encontrado apoyo
la ong hielo atiende a una treintena de
niños que vienen de poblaciones
alcanzadas por la guerra la mayoría han
sido testigos de bombardeos y vivieron
largos períodos en refugios subterráneos
como ver check de 3 años que tenía
demoras en su desarrollo y estaba
evolucionando muy bien hasta que llegó
la guerra y todo se detuvo
en nuestra ciudad todo estaba cerrado
está está miedoso contarle que comíamos
esos días pero así fue cómo sobrevivimos
o no sé si se le puede llamar sobrevivir
porque no sabemos qué pasará después
el niño empezó a necesitar pañales y el
miedo se apoderó de él se encerró en sí
mismos desde hace menos de un mes asiste
varias veces por semana la terapia poco
a poco se recupera esto es un alivio
para la madre pero acaban sus problemas
la mayoría de familias han perdido sus
casas y muchas de ellas saben que no
podrán regresar a sus poblaciones un
gran número de ellas en poder de las
fuerzas rusas
las malas gestiones gubernamentales los
atentados de 2019 en colombo y los
efectos de la pandemia devastadora seri
lanka un país que quedó sumido en su
peor crisis económica desde la
independencia de reino unido en 1948 una
inflación interanual superior al 50 por
ciento escasez de alimentos combustibles
o medicamentos llevaron a miles de
personas a las calles obligando al
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa a huir del
país y posteriormente a renunciar los
jóvenes los principales actores de estas
revueltas no ven un futuro claro en su
país y por eso muchos piensan en la
posibilidad de buscar una nueva vida en
el extranjero informe de una bolita con
mar y albany álvarez y dimita a rne hay
aquí
esta es la zona cero de las recientes
protestas en civil anka se llama a la
aldea gota gamma que lleva el nombre del
expresidente gotabaya rajapaksa
desde hace más de 100 días los
manifestantes acampan aquí en alfaz en
el corazón de colombo
este movimiento está liderado por
jóvenes entre 20 y 30 años como ti zara
999 al principio no vine aquí para
quedarme solo quería visitar el lugar y
cuando vi los sacrificios de la gente de
aquí me conmovió y decidí quedarme para
ayudarles para ti zara no hay otra forma
de asegurar su futuro que unirse a este
movimiento
si no puedes cumplir tus sueños aquí en
este momento es mejor emigrar a otro
país yo aconsejaría de los jóvenes que
se fueran si tienen los medios pero yo
no puedo ir no tengo dinero
para decenas de miles de jóvenes
desesperados decir blanca la única
opción para escapar del aumento de los
precios y del desempleo es abandonar el
país en la oficina de pasaportes de
colombo todos los días hay nuevos
solicitantes llevo tres días esperando
tengo muchas ganas de ir al extranjero
ahora kate moss la mayoría de mis amigos
intentan ir a dubai y kuwait para
trabajos de limpieza
en las afueras de colombo nos
encontramos con manu un ingeniero de
software de 26 años gana 400 euros al
mes que era un sueldo alto hasta que
llegó la crisis económica ahora busca
trabajo en singapur
si me voy al extranjero no podré
llevarme a mi familia de inmediato
pero puedo enviarles dinero para que
puedan sobrevivir según los informes del
gobierno más de 320.000 seis grandes
solicitaron pasaportes en los últimos
seis meses mientras que en 2020 sólo
fueron 200.000
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]